[Music]
you apparently get a ton of mail from
from from male admirers I get some fan
mail from some dudes I sure do yeah yes
I do
yeah that that's where I got that
picture that is one of my fan followers
right there really that fan mate oh no
no no no I'm saying the body of my head
there is is one of my followers I'm oh
really
so what is the what are you finding is
is there a pattern to the kind of person
that's attracted to you well I mean I
get a wide variety of people that are
attracted to me but in the in the gay
community I get some pretty burly guys
that are interested in in hitting this
right this in later sessions right
that's been be given that than this much
more than I asked
to be fair a simple question and we went
down a whole road I have said from the
beginning I never in a million years
thought I would have fans and I accept
all my fans no matter how much body hair
they have oh and prison
I have gotten some some prison mail I
have gotten some prison mail some very
uncomfortable prison move it uh what is
it like I'm gonna come see you when I
get out I want more of like I want you
to come see me here yeah make the trip
out to forget the name of the town this
one particular gentleman was in but
would like asked me to come visit him on
a weekend right imprisonment I mean I
think there's a place they go outside a
prison to have conjugal visits I don't
know that I would you guys are so
uncomfortable right now guys we didn't
sign up for this we came for a Hollywood
family family taping prison I say we
send a camera crew and we find out
but the first the first season I got
some pretty explicit fan mail of things
that gentleman would like to do to me
sure sure and I was you guys are still
yeah okay
those people are leaving that let's talk
about you love to prank your co-star
Jesse Jesse Tyler Ferguson you love
pranking him what kind of pranks do you
play on him well the first thing I did
to him we were at one of the first
things I did to him we were shooting the
episode in Hawaii and we were in up a
pool that overlooked this beautiful area
of where people get married at this
particular hotel and it's just he and I
like leaning on the the edge of this
infinity pool and there's a big group of
people about to get married so I just
yelled hey do you like my work on Modern
Family and then just went underwater
[Laughter]
I've one day we were shooting in a look
on location we were in a dusty parking
lot so his car was covered with dust and
so I wrote my name's Jesse Tyler
Ferguson I live in a mansion and I'm
well hung he didn't notice that people
were walking by all day like there was a
day we had like hundreds of background
actors there so they all saw this and
then just recently we were in Las Vegas
shooting an episode and we were in the
middle of the casino the Mandalay Bay
there and I go hey I'm the redheaded guy
on Modern Family and then I just go just
blend into the crowd we were a terrible
terrible man I'm a horrible person